ich habe die BILD am SONNTAG gelesen
Pfingsten und die hat mir fast das
Pfingstfest verdorben weil ein
erschütternder Bericht drin war nämlich
über die Zustände in den Pflegeheimen
und die Kosten für die Pflegeheime und
das erschütternde war dass der Chef
eines dieser Pflegeheim der sicherlich
nicht wenig verdient gesagt hat wenn ich
ein Pflegefall würde könnte ich mir mein
eigenes Heim nicht leisten ganz zu
schweigen von den Pflegern die noch
weniger verdient ich glaube wir sind
heute dabei die Welt zu retten aber wir
gucken nicht was wird mit Oma und Opa
die haben mir das Klima wir hatten
Corona wir haben Milliarden für alles
aber eben nur nicht für unsere Zukunft
denn diese Zukunft werden wir alle haben
es gibt zu wenig Krankenhäuser
Lauterbach will ja noch mehr schließen
es gibt kaum mehr Pflegepersonal wer
will das auch schon machen die Kosten
explodieren es gibt auch kaum mehr
Hausärzten die klassischen Ärzte wandern
ab ich komme gerade von der schönen
Insel Amrum da habe ich vier Ärzte auf
dieser winzigen Insel getroffen als
Gäste die mich ansprachen und sagen wir
sitzen aufgepackten Koffern und hauen ab
also wir wollen die Erde retten aber wir
haben
kein Geld für
Oma und Opa die oder auch wir die einmal
alt werden ich kann nur an die junge
Generation die meint sie müssen sich
jetzt überall auf die Straße kleben
sagen ihr die ihr heute klebt werdet
übermorgen unter der Brücke landen es
sei denn ihr seid Millionäre es
funktioniert einfach nicht mehr und das
ist etwas wo ich die Politik einfach
Aufrufe wir haben 16 Jahre lang
Gesundheitsminister gehabt von CDU und
CSU wir haben SPD Register gehabt heute
haben wir Herrn Lauterbach die haben
dies Problem alle verschlafen und ich
glaube jetzt ist die Zeit wo wir sagen
müssen aufwachen und Prioritäten setzen
gerade den Punkt angesprochen weswegen
ich sehr verwundert über ihre
Erschütterung bin als ich finde es ganz
toll dass ihnen die Bild so gut gefällt
und es für so viel Furore bei ihnen
sorgt aber sie haben doch ob Anfang der
2000er immer Spitzenpolitikern geführt
da werden sie doch auch über die Pflege
geredet haben immer dieses Thema aber
wie kann ich sie dann so er ja es
erschüttert mich deshalb weil wir
plötzlich ja Geld haben für alles also
wir haben ja Nein früher war es in dem
extrem extrem
nein es wurde nicht gespart unbedingt
aber es wurde nicht wir rechnen die
heute nicht mehr in Millionen sondern
mindestens in Milliarden und ähm wir
haben für alles plötzlich Geld wir haben
für diese ganze Corona Geschichte die
sich heute auch im Blick auflege und
Gesundheit als die größte
Strophe der Nachkriegszeit herausstellt
wir haben die psychisch gestörten die
einsamen die die furchtbar leidenden
alten Leute wir haben die Impfschäden um
die sich keiner kümmert und wir haben
die Kinder die wir kaputt gemacht haben
und dafür haben wir Milliarden zum
Fenster rausgeworfen
scheint gestorben zu sein die
Verantwortlichen kein Politiker will
verantwortlich sein das ist doch alles
unfassbar und jetzt überlegen Sie alle
Augenblick man hätte diese Milliarden in
das Gesundheitssystem gesteckt in die
Pflegeversicherung und so weiter ich
sehe heute völlig anders aus wir gehen
einer Katastrophe entgegen wir machen
wir doch mal den Check und Fragen Wähler
anders ob es noch nie vorher vorgekommen
ist also früher wirklich einfach kein
Geld für die Pflege da war und jetzt
haben wir ganz viel Geld Gold Töpfe wo
Geld da ist
Pflegeversicherung gibt es ja schon seit
längerer Zeit und Gott sei Dank gibt es
sie aber sie reicht natürlich nicht aus
die Maßnahmen die unter der Agenda 2010
ins Werk gesetzt worden sind um den
Staat zu entlasten sind ja alle
zurückgenommen worden und Rente Zeit
wurde verkürzt auf Rente bei bis 63
runtergekürzt es gab eine
pauschale die man zahlt wenn man in
einen ein zum Arzt musste um und das hat
die Krankenkassen massiv entlastet hat
natürlich viel Aufregung gesorgt von
alle möglichen auch Bild damals sehr
furchtbar im Nachhinein hat man dann
andere Meinung aber
das war so und es hat allerdings die
Kasten gefüllt es hat die Menschen
länger an Arbeit gehalten zwangsweise
aber ist auch die dafür dass diese Dinge
alle bezahlt werden konnten dann hat man
gesagt wir haben ja Geld und hat dieses
Geld und muss man einfach gesagt einfach
weiter rausgegeben immer soziale
Wohltaten dazu gesetzt die Arbeitszeit
verkürzt und aus diesem Grund ist nun
kein Geld mehr da und mein Doktor zeigt
mehr als 10 Jahren an diesem das Thema
rum hat auch so ein Gesetz auf den Weg
gebracht triple-win heißt das wo man
Leute die Möglichkeit gibt hier
Pflegepersonal zu stellen aus
Bosnien-Herzegowina aus Vietnam können
sie kommen erbärmlich wenn man mal
überlegt dass es hier in diesem Land
Status Quo ist es gibt bis 2035 1,8
Millionen offene Stellen in der Pflege
hat man errechnet und die werden auch
nicht gefüllt ist können wir selbst was
auf den Weg gebracht werden soll was die
Situation ändern soll aber wir warten
mal ab was das ganze mit einem das auf
den Punkt wir haben bald Pflegeheime die
eine Wärmepumpe haben und haben draußen
einen Windrad stehen nur sie haben
keinen mehr der in diesem Heim ist weil
die einen ist nicht bezahlen können und
die anderen dort nicht arbeiten wollen
das ist die Katastrophe auf den Punkt
gebracht hat oder wie kann das unser
Gesundheitssystem jetzt habe ich nicht
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht wie
gesund ich heute bin weil ich hier sitze
nein das ist ich weiß nicht krank ich
weiß es in England genauso krank da hat
man auch furchtbare Horrorgeschichten
aber es ist sie haben vollkommen recht
es ist eine Frage der Prioritäten es
kann mir doch niemand sagen dass kein
Geld da ist das Geld muss nur auf andere
Zwecke ausgegeben werden weil sie vorhin
von Asyl und Aufnahme gesprochen haben
ich finde seltsam dass es keinen Budget
Posten gibt Flüchtlingshilfe das
irgendwie finde den recherchiere
investigative Kollegen sich diese Zahlen
zusammen herzaubern müssen die dann
wahrscheinlich unter der übertrieben
sind geld ist genug da wir haben über
100 gender Lehrstühle und ich glaube nur
180.2018 also das Geld ist da ist man
kann mir überhaupt nicht sein dass du
dein Problem ist schauen Sie wir
schaffen Sondervermögen zum ersten Mal
in der Geschichte der Nationalökonomie
heißen Schulden Vermögen wie hoch ist
denn ihr Vermögen Arme so also man kann
das Geld zaubern Europäische Zentralbank
drückt auf dem Knopf und spuckt 1000
liebe Frau Teuteberg möchte
zur Wahrheit gehört ja schon auch dass
wir bei der Pflege so sehr man vieles
verbessern kann wir haben wirklich ein
demografisches Problem das heißt selbst
dann wenn viele Dinge besser gemacht
werden bleibt es dabei wir haben einfach
deutlich weniger junge Menschen im
Erwerbstätigen Alter und viele
ältere Menschen und das führt sehr wohl
erstmal zu einem Problem bei der Frage
wie viel Menschen stehen zur Verfügung
um Pflege auch zu gewährleisten und das
ist durchaus eine finanzielles Problem
das haben wir ja nicht anders
nein aber nein nein das ist nicht nein
nein das ist wirklich unhöflich sein
auch gerade gegenüber Damen nicht aber
ich will das ist das und und sie sind
jemand der für ihre Form steht und für
eine Reform Geist und sowas deswegen
will ich das nicht mit ihnen in
Verbindung bringen aber grundsätzlich
immer es ist die Beschreibung eines
Problems aber dass wir schon doch seit
ewigen Zeiten ändern
thematisiert auch übrigens als das
vollen Händen ausgegeben wurde vor
Corona angesprochen dass wir eben keinen
Abo auf diesen Wohlstand haben und dass
wir demografische Probleme haben Rente
mit 63 und viele andere Dinge Schritte
in die falsche Richtung sind also wir
müssen da vieles tun wir müssen
einerseits dafür sorgen wie verbessern
wir die Einnahme Basis dass die Menschen
die arbeiten können auch länger arbeiten
wenn sie länger gesund leben dass die
eine Sache wir müssen Pflegekräfte und
medizinisches Personal von einigen
bürokratischen Pflichten befreien damit
sie mehr ihre Arbeitszeit auch wirklich
sich den Patienten und den zu pflegenden
Menschen zuwenden können wir müssen
vieles tun wir müssen übrigens auch
unpopulärer Weise tatsächlich bei den
krankenhausstrukturen einiges tun denn
so sehr wir genügend Versorgung brauchen
wir müssen daran auch was ändern wir
haben heute höhere Ansprüche als früher
an die sogenannte sozusagen an die
Schwarzwaldklinik wenn wir heute eine
moderne Ausstattung bestimmte
Spezialisierung können wir nicht in
jedem Krankenhaus vorhalten wir müssen
da ein bisschen schauen was ist
Grundversorgung was sind spezialkassen
also auch für die Schließung nicht
pauschal aber wir müssen genau wir
müssen gut gucken was brauchen wir an
welcher Stelle damit wir die
Pflegekräfte die Ärztin Ärzte die wir
haben da einsetzen wo wir sie brauchen
wir haben davon nicht beliebig viele
ihre Heimat in Brandenburg nicht mehr
sehen lassen da müssen Leute 80 km zum
Hausarzt fahren 100 km schauen
ich höre seit zehn Jahren immer nur wir
müssen sagen Sie doch einmal nicht was
wir müssen sondern was haben wir getan
alles was sie sagen ist richtig aber es
ist der Schnee von vorgestern das ist
x-fach schon durchgehauen durch
diskutiert worden nein
nicht umgesetzt worden ein vernünftiges
Ausländer und Einwanderungsrecht ist
auch nicht umgesetzt worden und dann
überlegen Sie was alles umgesetzt wurde
die Energiewende die Milliarden aber
dieses Jahr wollte auch nicht
diskutieren das gehört auch zur Wahrheit
im Bundestagswahlkampf 2021 haben nicht
viele über Migration
nein
dass wir uns mit dem Problem leider oft
auch erst beschäftigen und viele sich
nur dafür interessieren wenn es gerade
ganz akut ist und es sonst auch nicht so
gerne sind Politikern vor Beruf sind
sozusagen der Müllmann oder die
Müllfahrer der Nation bei ihnen landet
ist völlig zurecht und sie müssen sich
damit beschäftigen und ich werde sauer
und ärgerlich weil ich immer höre wir
müssen wir müssen wir müssen das kann
beim Kindergarten an es gibt einen
gesetzlichen Anspruch auf Kitaplätze es
gibt nur keine Kita-Plätze das ist die
deutsche Philosophie der letzten Jahre
also sagen Sie bitte nicht ständig wir
müssen ich schließe mich da aus ich muss
gar nichts aber zum Thema Migration
passt es ja in sofern
Leute
bevor jetzt sie beide auch die
Müllmänner aber auch Frau Teutoburg
machen
Bruder
hat natürlich auch die Möglichkeit sie
hat die Möglichkeit zu gestalten zu
machen umzusetzen zu tun
realistische Lösungen sein man kann
natürlich den Menschen alles mögliche
versprechen und dann die Schulden machen
die Herr Broder dann kritisiert dass die
dann verharmlost werden oder man kann
sagen was können wir tun und wie können
wir es organisieren
das ist das Problem durch die kommen zum
ersten Thema zurück durch die Migration
wen holen sie denn hier kommen Leute
österreich hat ja den Mut gehabt dass
jetzt mal
zur recherchieren Punkt zu bringen 70%
der jungen Leute die hierher kommen
können wieder lesen noch schreiben sie
holen also Leute in Sozialsystem und
Licht im Pflegeberufe oder sowas das
heißt es gibt auch Leute die kommen hin
können nicht lesen und schreiben und
können nach einem Jahr lesen und
schreiben einen solchen Fall habe ich
gerade eben kennengelernt das sollten
wir nicht nein
nur der Großteil leider nicht und die
sitzen im Sozialsystem
mal eine abschließende Frage zu ihr
diese wie würden Sie denn das Geld
verteilen also sie sind jetzt
Bundeskanzler was würden Sie tun das bin
ich Gott sei Dank nicht denn wenn ich es
werde einfacher ist nein das hat nichts
mit meckern zu tun mein Beruf wie ich
ihn verstehe und wie ich ihn vor 50
Jahren gelernt habe ist kein
hofjournalismus sondern alles
hinterfragen alles kritisieren und
deswegen habe ich seit drei Jahren
diesen corona-mist kritisiert und ja
seitdem ich im Journalismus bin habe ich
auf die Migration gewesen wir kommen
nicht zum Abladen sondern zum
kritisieren da bin ich beides habe ich
auch in der Journalistenschule ja aber
die Frage ist denn das Geld
denn jetzt hingeben also
die Frage ist doch was Hendrik Bode eben
mit dem Wort zurecht Prioritäten setzen
gesagt das heißt
er ich jetzt versuche an deutschen Wesen
soll die Welt genesen die gesamte Welt
zu retten mit allen drei Prius Prio 1 2
3 also für mich ist die absolute
Priorität die Kinder also Kita
Grundschule die Grundausbildung wir
müssen uns doch schämen in welche
Schulen wir heute unsere Kinder schicken
wo die Klos nicht funktionieren wo alles
dreckig und kaputt ist
und zweitens natürlich die andere Seite
der Gesellschaft die hilflosen das sind
die alten die können sich nicht mehr
wehren die werden abgeschoben das heißt
die alles was mit Pflege zu tun hat was
mit Heimen zu und so weiter und dann das
dritte Frauen ich sehe Herrn
das ist ja der Witz wenn Sie ein
Frauenministerium haben gehen Sie davon
aus dass Frauen etwas Besonders
schützenswertes sind würde ich mich
dagegen wehren in der Mehrheit nein aber
das Minderheit behandelt aber ihre
dritte Priorität ja
die dritte Priorität ist
Bildung Bildung Bildung Bildung ohne
Sinn kommen wir nicht weiter aber nur
noch ein Wort zu dieser Geld Frage nein
wirklich wenn mich das aufregt sie
sprechen doch jetzt selber in ihrem
Zimmer noch über Geld ein anderes Geld
wir können nicht weiter behaupten es
Fehler an Geld als der Bundeskanzler zu
Herrn Lola vor hat er 200 Millionen Euro
als Geschenk mitgebracht wir haben
Abholung der Regenwälder wir haben 600
Millionen Euro in einem Anflug von
Größen waren und Idiotie an die Taliban
überwiesen in der absoluten Hoffnung es
würde schon an der richtigen Quelle
landen wir unterstützen Türkei
beim Annäherungsprozess an der
Europäische Union mit über einer halben
Milliarde wir schicken Entwicklungshilfe
an China und da kommt nette feine
gesunde tüchtige intelligente Leute wie
ihr und ich höre immer noch es ist kein
Geld da es ist zu viel Geld da das ist
das Problem